(children talking)
- What were you all discussing?
- Nothing.
- [Whitney Holland] I've seen
a lot of my kids this year,
instead of just exploding,
getting really upset
they are aware of their emotions
and before lashing out they will be like,
"Okay, I need to go to the peace corner."
- [Mathew Portell] At Fall Hamilton
we have students
who are currently experiencing
some serious tragedy in their lives.
When they walk through the door they don't
leave everything at the door,
they bring it with them.
- Do you need to take a break?
Yeah?
- [Mathew] We're trying
to build the capacity
for them to be able to know what to do
when they're frustrated
or when they're angry.
So we're using peace corners.
- [Madisien Steele] There is a
peace corner in every classroom.
That is a place that a student
can go if they need a break.
If they just need a time out,
they're having a hard time.
There's gonna be some comfy
pillows or a bean bag.
There'll be some fidgets.
Different things to help
de-escalate the student.
- [Abby] If I get really frustrated
and feel like
I'm gonna yell or get mad at somebody,
I go to the peace corner
and just calm down.
- [Whitney] We set a five-minute
timer so they
know that they have five
minutes to cool down.
If it's really bad and
they need some extra time
I said they can flip it
again and take their time.
- [Abby] My teacher has this
sheet that you fill out.
It tells you how you feel,
what choice you made,
and what should you do to
make it better next time.
- [Madisien] There's also gonna be
some charts that talk about
breathing or counting or
different things a student
can do to de-escalate in the moment.
At the end of that time it's time to
reintegrate with the rest of the students.
- [Mathew] Every kid uses it so
it's not a place of stigma.
It's a place that we allow students
to utilize the strategies
that we're teaching them.
- Ready to go?
- [Whitney] We've seen a huge shift
in behavior.
There's not as many outbursts,
there's not as many arguments
'cause they've realized their emotions,
they're understanding
them, and they're able to
make that decision to go sit
down at the peace corner.
(children talking)